hello out there
everybody settled in your Quantum
popcorn and your Jujubes ready to go
okay it is a pleasure to welcome you
tonight to Einstein's Quantum riddle
which is going to be a multimedia
multi-part Extravaganza and it occurs uh
did I say who I am I am Brian Keating I
I'm so reluctant to talk about myself uh
I am Brian Keating a professor of
physics at UC San Diego and I am the
co-associate director of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination the
center with the longest name of any
Center on campus but that's for good
reason
yes thank you very much for choosing the
name uh the center tonight is very proud
to present a discussion a screening and
a a wonderful uh Extravaganza which I
should point out is occurring just 10
days before the 100 and something
birthday of Albert Einstein a picture of
whom appears up there when he was a
younger gentleman and proposing some of
the wild wacky ideas that we're going to
talk about tonight and see in this
wonderful Nova special
so I want to welcome you tonight on
behalf of the Arthur C Clarke Center and
remind you that we run a series of
events here at the Arthur C Clarke
Center including events like this but
also workshops for writers for authors
for public for the public to interact
with artists scientists and the like and
tonight is is going to be you know
really red meat evening for geeks out
there so I'm really excited about it
tonight
so the way the evening is going to go
I'm going to talk for the next 27
minutes now I'm going to talk for a
couple minutes I'm going to introduce uh
the one of the stars of tonight's
program Dr Andrew Freeman who Friedman
who's a research scientist who works
with me at the center for astrophysics
and space Sciences close second to the
Arthur C Clarke Center and he's going to
present some initial slides and
discussion to sort of wet your appetite
for the Nova special that he appears in
along with Dr Jason galicio who is a
professor at Harvey Mudd College and now
I want to give them their formal due
their formal introduction so Andrew
Friedman is assistant research scientist
ucsd's Center for astrophysics and space
sciences and he is an affiliate of our
Arthur C Clark Center he's an astronomer
a cosmologist and he leverages new
techniques and and advanced theories to
learn more about the universe from the
smallest scales the quantum realm all
the way up to the grandest most
extravagant scales namely the entire
universe he was an undergraduate at UC
Berkeley up north and he was a fellow or
he was graduate student Harvard
University and then a postdoctoral
fellow at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and he joined our group here
in San Diego in 2017 after many years
working together we finally got him to
be a permanent employee of this fine
Institution
his friend and colleague Jason galicio
is over there and you'll meet him and
you'll see a lot of him in the video
tonight which is appropriate because he
is our official representative from
Hollywood California he is an assistant
professor of physics at Harvey Mudd
College he focuses on experimental
cosmology and Quantum Optics he did
undergraduate degrees in phys and
electrical and computer engineering from
University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign
he completed his physics PhD at Harvard
University did a postdoctoral fellowship
at UC Davis and the University of
Chicago before joining Harvey Mudd in
2016. in 2013 he became relatively
famous in our small circle of
experimental cosmologists when he spent
a year of his entire life at the bottom
of the world at the Edmondson Scott
Southpaw research station working on the
South Pole telescopes
and last but not least is Dr David Brin
who will be one of the third member of
the panel tonight he was trained as a
scientist before going on to a
successful career as a science fiction
author and a winner of many many awards
and he is currently a scholar in
Residence at the Arthur C Clarke Center
he did an undergraduate degree
and astronomy from a small Technical
College in Pasadena known as Caltech and
then he did his PhD right here at UCSD
in applied physics and space science
he's a science fictional writer as I
said he won many awards including a Hugo
a nebula award for his uplift Universe
novels including star tide rising uplift
War his Standalone novel The Postman was
the winner of both the Campbell and
Locust science fiction Awards and turned
into a major science fiction movie
starring Kevin Costner so he's also part
Hollywood several of other novels have
gone on to great acclaim and I just want
to say on behalf of the entire Clark
Center Community what a pleasure it is
to have these three distinguished
scientists who are also masters of
communication and I think that's very
rare and and it's it's very nice to be
able to share with you the public the
people that pay our salaries and our
taxes with your taxes thank you very
much and please keep doing so to uh to
support this intellectual Center which
we think of a little tiny gem within the
jewel of La Jolla so I welcome you
tonight and now I call up to the stage
my good friend and colleague Dr Andrew
Friedman
all right thank you so much Brian can
you guys hear me
yeah it's wonderful to be here I'd like
to thank everyone at the office of the
Clark Center including Brian Patrick
Coleman Eric vire and the director
Sheldon brown for making this event
possible and a special thanks to the
Gordon and Betty Moore Foundation for
supporting this event as well as the
Nova episode itself I'd also like to
thank WGBH Boston for producing the film
and for uh helping with previous Nova
screening events at Harvey Mudd College
and MIT
and I'd like to thank several guests
from KPBS San Diego our local PBS
station who are here today
I'd also like to thank not only Brian
but my fellow panelists Jason glicchio
and David Brin uh Brian and David and I
have had the opportunity to do a few
public Outreach events here at the Clark
Center before so it's nice to be
continuing that tradition
and it's great to bring science fiction
writers together with Scientists to talk
about some of the most mind-blowing
stuff in the universe
and uh Jason Plays a starring role in
the Nova documentary as we'll see and he
and I came up with the idea for this
experiment together and Jason has been
with me from the very beginning so thank
you so much Jason for everything that
you've done Brian has been extremely
supportive of the project from the very
early stages and just I just wanted to
say to each of you this this couldn't
have happened without your help so thank
you thank you guys so much
so
as somebody who grew up watching Nova
it's it's really just kind of amazing
and hard to express how cool it is that
they made a TV documentary about our
work and as the the flagship Science
Education Program at PBS Nova has you
know set the standard you know for so
many years in today's world public
understanding of science is is more
important than ever and science is just
the the best process we have to
understand the world and to promote
critical thinking and enable us to make
complex decisions and in an uncertain
world and I'm certainly biased but
science is just also so incredibly
mind-blowing and it belongs to everybody
not just the people who are lucky enough
to do it for a living so I hope that
tonight's event will continue to spread
the excitement of what it's like to be
involved at some research at the
Forefront of scientific knowledge and in
in these in these opening remarks I'm
going to take the opportunity to tell a
story which is you know a personal story
about what for me has been nothing less
than the scientific journey of a
lifetime and I've been able to work with
amazing scientists this from all around
the world on a crazy experiment where we
use the entire universe to learn
something about
quantum mechanics the theory of nature
on the smallest of scales and we we are
specifically interested in the
phenomenon of quantum entanglement and
we use astronomical observations of
distant galaxies to help us understand
this phenomenon and
in this Spirit I'm going to share some
stories some behind the scenes things
that didn't quite make it into the
documentary including the uphill battle
that it took to make this experiment
happen as well as some near disasters
where it really seemed like the universe
was trying to destroy our experiment
before it started
and I'll also try to give some
additional background on the main
scientific and philosophical issues
which are at stake
so one of the most amazing things about
being a scientist is when when you have
an opportunity to work on a project
which attracts the attention of the
science media and so these are some of
the stories that came out after the
publication of our paper last year that
is the subject of the documentary and
you know to put things in context if you
if you write a scientific paper it's
considered successful if a few dozen
people cite it and maybe if a few
hundred people read it but by contrast
when the science media gets involved
you can actually communicate your ideas
to thousands hundreds of thousands
sometimes even millions of people and so
uh my friend and colleague David Kaiser
from MIT who also features heavily in
the documentary told us that this
episode Einstein's Quantum riddle earned
a 1.8 National household rating which
actually beat out the Big Bang Theory
for that week which is pretty cool
and it it reeks to whopping 3.5 million
viewers and so that's that the leverage
that you get when you're able to
communicate in the in these platforms is
just so much greater than what what we
we scientists get to do in our normal
sort of career so we're just so
incredibly excited to get to share the
story with with so many people including
all of you here today
so to put the story in a larger context
quantum theory is our best fundamental
theory of the subatomic world it's been
with us for nearly a hundred years and
it's been extremely well tested
experimentally
by some estimates 30 to 40 percent of
the GDP of the world is based on Quantum
enabled technology so you're talking
about transistors you know lasers like
this laser pointer semiconductors
digital displays so basically all
computers TVs laptops smartphones
communication satellites I mean the list
goes on and on and in addition as the
documentary we'll go into more detail
about there are several emerging
technological
um applications in encryption and
computation that fundamentally rely on
quantum entanglement
so it despite the esoteric nature of the
subject because it's actually a very
practical subject today
but unfortunately
even though quantum mechanics has been
around for nearly a sanctuary experts
still disagree about what the Theory
actually means about the world about the
true nature of reality in other words
there's no consensus interpretation of
quantum theory and one of the most
tricky issues involves the nature and
meaning of quantum entanglement
so what is entanglement essentially it's
a phenomenon where you have pairs of
particles that maintain a special
connection no matter how far apart they
are from each other and no matter how
long ago they became entangled
and as soon as you measure some property
of one particle in the entangled
particle pair you instantly know
something about a future measurement
outcome on its partner and this is true
even though on either side the
measurement outcomes can appear to be
completely random
so Einstein himself didn't like quantum
entanglement and didn't like quantum
mechanics and he dismissed the
phenomenon as so-called spooky action at
a distance
since it seemed to violate his his
theory of special relativity which held
that no information can travel faster
than the speed of light and while we now
know that you can't actually use
entanglement to transmit information
faster than light sadly it's still true
that the phenomenon of entanglement is
something that we admittedly don't know
how to tell a convincing story about
that that tells us what's really going
on
and Einstein hoped that eventually some
other fundamental Theory more
fundamental than quantum mechanics would
eventually come around to explain
entanglement
so in in his skepticism towards quantum
theory Einstein advocated a world view
which has come to be called local
realism and for many years his worldview
seemed to be primarily a philosophical
one disconnected from any real world
experiments or tests but in the 1960s
John Bell a famous physicist
took some of Einstein's ideas formalized
them mathematically and actually came up
with a way to do an experiment which
could distinguish between quantum
mechanics and these alternative models
that Einstein so wanted to be true so
this theoretical result called Bell's
inequality it's derived from
starting point of several extremely
reasonable sounding assumptions about
the world
so one of them is realism and this is
just the idea that the the real world
exists independent of our observations
and objects have definitive properties
whether we measure them or not
Bell also assumed locality
which is the idea that if two distance
systems are far away from each other
nothing you do to system one can
instantly affect system two and vice
versa and this is of course motivated by
Einstein's theory of relativity and and
lastly the most subtle assumption that
Einstein made implicitly but but Bell
made explicit and this is actually the
Assumption we're most interested in with
the experiment that will be the subject
of the documentary is the idea of
freedom or freedom of choice
when you measure entangled particles
you're making a choice about how to
measure them and
Bell's results assume that this is a
perfectly free choice in the sense that
it is uncorrelated with any hidden
information in the past of the
experiment that's missing from quantum
theory that could affect the entangled
particles and this turns out to be a
rather subtle assumption but if you put
them all together you get Bell's
inequality which in practice
predicts that there should be an upper
limit to how often the measurement
outcomes could line up in an entangled
particle test
so
Decades of experiments have shown that
the upper limit from Bell's inequality
is actually violated we see more
correlation between the measurement
outcomes than would seem to be possible
from these local realistic models that
Einstein wanted to be true and the usual
story to explain what's going on is that
you've got to give up realism or
locality or both some of you may have
heard that in quantum mechanics one of
the one of the many standard
interpretations is that objects don't
have definite properties Until You
observe them that's what happens when
you drop this assumption people often
talk about quantum mechanics being
so-called non-local even though it
doesn't actually violate relativity and
you can't transmit information faster
than light
uh but what's really
um definitive about Bell violation and
experiments plus spells inequality is
that the conjunction of all these three
assumptions cannot be true in nature so
at least one of them has to be wrong
but
there unfortunately really isn't any
theoretical guidance they all seem
incredibly reasonable
and
we're most interested in the possibility
of this third assumption
and some of our recent theoretical work
has shown that if you keep realism in
locality
but you slightly relax Freedom which
means that the choices that are made in
experiment you don't have as many
options as you thought you did
it would be possible still for a
non-quantum theory to explain
entanglement But ultimately our
experiment is designed to put some
tension on this third assumption about
freedom of choice
so
why do these things matter
well from a fundamental physics
standpoint we want to know about the
fundamental nature of reality we want to
know you know does the moon exist when
we're not looking at it we want to know
is there hidden influence traveling
faster than light and what's going on
there and we we want to know are our
choices actually free in experiments uh
is there a deeper Theory under the hood
of quantum mechanics like Einstein
wanted to be true that could explain
entanglement in a way that makes more
sense
but independent of this there's lots of
practical reasons why we're also
interested in this and the documentary
we'll go into this a little bit more
they're major emerging technologies that
are based on quantum entanglement
including computation Technologies and
encryption Technologies and every three
letter agency in the world every
national government major corporation
has a stake and whether or not these
technologies will work
um Quantum encryption in particular is
poised to replace the classical
encryption schemes that protect all of
our online bank transactions today and
physicists think that the quantum
encryption should be perfectly secure
but if it turns out that there's a
deeper Theory under the hood of quantum
mechanics then it might be possible in
principle to break these Quantum
encryption schemes
so there's a lot of practical reasons
for being interested in this these
seemingly esoteric ideas
so in an abstract picture of an
entanglement test you have a central
source of entangled particles which
sends out particles
to two distant detectors typically we
talk about Alice and Bob on either side
of the experiment as experimenters they
choose some measurement settings
so for example let's say that the
entangled particles are photons
particles of light that are entangled
with respect to their polarization
the measurements you make might be very
very similar to you can see these
polarized sunglasses here if I if I
choose to rotate them at a certain angle
I'm actually asking a certain question
of the particle on either side so these
are the kinds of experimental choices
that we're actually talking about where
we rotate a polarizing filter that's
very similar to these polarized
sunglasses
and the photon will either go through
the the the filter or it'll get absorbed
in the filter uh camera behind it
records what's going on and and that's
what the measurement outcome is it
either goes through or it doesn't
and when we do these experiments we see
more correlation between the measurement
outcomes than would be allowed in these
local realistic models that Einstein
wanted to be true
but what we're concerned with in our
experiment is this question of these
these little choices of measurements
things like
the choices of the the angle of the
polarizing filter are these really free
choices
um are there is there any information in
the past that could in principle allow
us to predict better than chance what
these choices would be so
how do you actually choose measurement
settings in an entanglement test well in
the simplest case you could let people
make the choices
state of the art tasks up until recently
use things that are called Quantum
random number generators
but these are devices that are located
on Earth
and it's possible in principle that
events milliseconds beforehand could
have causally influenced one or both of
these experimental devices
so
based on causality alone we can't
actually know for sure that the
purportedly random numbers that are
being spit out by these devices are are
truly random and not influenced by
earlier events that become correlated
with them so maybe in principle there's
there's information in the past that
could allow you to predict uh better
than chance what the next random number
would be
so how do we get around this well our
first so-called Cosmic Bell test in 2017
Outsource these choices to the universe
and pointed telescopes up at stars on
our own Galaxy and use the Starlight the
color of the Starlight like a random
number generator to make these choices
now what this does is that it tells you
that wherever the choice was made it was
made far away in space and time so we
did this experiment we saw a violation
of Bell's limit more correlation than
would be expected in these alternative
models and we can't rule out entirely
that they are responsible for
entanglement but what we can say is that
uh it had to have happened far in the
past so the nearest star was 600 light
years away in this experiment in
particular so an alternative Theory
would have had to have set things in
motion 600 years ago and this was a
dramatic improvement over previous tests
where the the limit was only a few
milliseconds before the experiment
and in in 2018 this is the subject of
the documentary we went even further
instead of using stars in our own Galaxy
we used distant galaxies entirely these
bright galaxies called quasars which
emitted their light not hundreds or
thousands of years ago but billions of
years ago
so this is what our Cosmic Bell
experiment in the Canary Islands
actually looked like so in January 2018
we sent a polarized entangled photons
through the open air
to these detectors that were located
near these two big telescopes that were
separated by about a kilometer and for
the first time while the entangled
particles were in flight
we waited for a fresh random bit of
information based on the color of the
light from each Quasar to cues how to
measure the entangled particles all
while they were still in flight and we
needed to do this very rapidly to make
sure that no hidden information could go
from one side of the experiment to
another in order to mimic and and fake
Quantum entangle but using some other
some other Theory and by Outsourcing the
choices to the universe
again we can't totally rule out
alternative explanations distinct from
quantum mechanics from explaining
entanglement but we can push them into a
very very far Corner in the past
in this case we can push things back
billions of years ago almost all the way
back to the beginning of the universe
gears a little bit to provide some
backstory before I came to UCSD in 2017
over the past six years or so to design
and Implement our experiment we've built
a unique collaboration at UCSD MIT
Harvey Mudd University of Vienna and
elsewhere so this is a good opportunity
to tell some behind the scenes stories
from my perspective of how this project
came into being
so my own personal involvement with the
project began just over six and a half
years ago at John Harvard's Brew Pub in
Cambridge Massachusetts and at that time
I was a postdoc at MIT and Jason galicio
was in town visiting from his postdoc at
the University of Chicago and we had
both gone to grad school at Harvard so
John Harvard's was a very familiar place
where many burgers and appetizers have
gone missing over the years and it was
the night of my wife's bachelorette
party and While She Was Out With Friends
Jason and I were talking physics over
dinner and Beverages and the idea of
quantum entanglement tests came up and
Jason talked about
his idea of using the oldest light in
the universe the so-called Cosmic
microwave background radiation to make
experimental choices in an entanglement
test and this sounded pretty cool as a
thought experiment and but since my
background was an infrared and Optical
astronomy I naturally wondered if there
might be other astronomical sources that
would suit our purposes better it might
be a little easier to work with and
these included things like exploding
Stars called supernovae and bright
distant galaxies called quasars and
these are things that are bright enough
to be seen halfway or all the way across
the universe and eventually I became
convinced that quasars were the best
choice and I was able to convince Jason
too and after this conversation I began
thinking about how far apart the quasars
had to be from each other and how far
away they had to be from us in order for
them to serve the purposes we had in
mind in the experiment and so these are
some notes with some of the theoretical
calculations that were relevant that
this conversation set in motion
so as the idea that Jason and I
discussed began to look more and more
promising I brought the idea to David
Kaiser my postdoctoral mentor at MIT who
was thankfully incredibly supportive and
enthusiastic and you know as as early
career scientist Jason and I knew that
there's just no way that we would ever
be able to do this experiment on our own
without help from people like Dave
and Dave and I soon began discussing
this idea with Alan Guth another eminent
theoretical physicist at MIT and as soon
as Alan became interested and was on
board I began to think cautiously maybe
this might actually happen but you know
amongst amongst us Jason is an
honest-to-goodness experimental
physicist but uh Dave and Allen and I
are astronomers and theoretical
cosmologists so we're not not people who
who work with experimental Hardware
admittedly so and we also know that we
needed a partner who really had the
required experimental expertise in
foundational Quantum experiments as well
as the funding and infrastructure uh and
and the the sway to actually convince an
observatory to let us do
this crazy thing with with these huge
telescopes and as it happened Professor
Anton zeilinger was from the University
of Vienna was was visiting MIT in
October 2013 to give the physics
colloquium and he he leads arguably one
of the world's top experimental Quantum
Optics groups and his team has already
performed a number of experiments
including entanglement tests in the
Canary Islands and uh realizing this
unique opportunity Dave and I signed up
to talk with him afterwards and we
cornered him with our experimental
proposal and to our Delight he was not
only incredibly enthusiastic he told us
he'd actually come up with the same idea
independently years ago and he was just
waiting for the right time to actually
do the experiment so by that time Dave
and Jason and I and Alan had already
solved some of the theoretical cosmology
problems needed to choose the right
astronomical sources in the experiment
and we'd started to convince ourselves
that it was going to be feasible with
present technology and so it turned out
to be the perfect Merit since each of
our groups had the expertise that the
other lacked and needed but a huge piece
was missing so
this was of course funding for the U.S
side of the collaboration and over the
next couple of years we applied for
Grants to support the project over and
over and kept hearing no after no after
no
and every time we submitted it to some
program we have kept hearing things like
well this is interesting but you really
should be submitting it to this other
agency and unfortunately that's that's
what you get in this very very tight
funding climate uh when your project
doesn't fit into a neat box and our our
project involved a unique combination of
observational astronomy theoretical
cosmology experimental Quantum Optics
and even aspects of the philosophy of
science so we ended up being penalized
for trying to do something unique and
interesting across several disciplines
and you know it was very very
frustrating especially since Anton and
his group were ready to go and they
thought it was really worth doing and in
the meantime I've been visiting UC San
Diego over several years and around
2013-14 he began to discuss this project
with Brian Keating who himself is one of
the world's leading experimental
cosmologists and I I was overjoyed when
Brian actually thought the project
sounded exciting and interesting and we
are so happy he agreed to join our our
latest funding proposal at the time to
get funding from the National Science
Foundation and thankfully after so much
frustration we found out in May 2015
that the NSF had funded our project and
you know as such you know Brian's
support from from the very early stages
had a huge huge role in the eventual
success of this experiment and uh the
this this funding allowed me to work at
MIT and then also to work on this
project at UCSD and I where I eventually
was able to come here a couple years ago
with Brian's help
and I've been able to work uh with a
number of amazing students including one
of Brian's graduate students David Leon
who helped with some of the key
theoretical cosmology calculations for
the project
so in in the end with NSF funding for
the U.S group and European funding from
from Anton's group for the experimental
hardware and the Manpower we were
finally in business and
thinking back it's it's pretty amazing
that the the thought experiment that
Jason and I envisioned actually happened
in the real world and and from idea to
completion it took just over six years
which is actually pretty fast in in
science and I I think it's safe to say
that the experiments exceeded beyond our
our wildest dreams
and I you know I just want to give again
a special thanks to Jason for being
being with me from the very beginning on
this project and uh you'll get to see a
lot of Jason in the documentary
so to go back almost to the beginning of
the universe uh we ultimately chose
quasars uh because they're the brightest
known astronomical objects at their
distance and at least on human time
skills they're always on so they're
they're bright and their brightness and
color
can be used as a ready source of random
numbers that were generated a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away
and we could use them to tell us how to
measure our entangled particles this is
exactly what we needed for our Cosmic
battle test but these quasars are really
faint objects so we needed fairly large
optical telescopes to observe them from
Earth and this is where we really needed
a place like the Canary Islands which
had exactly the right geography and
astronomical resources and we got an
amazing amount of support from people at
the Roque de las Machado Observatory on
the island of La Palma
thankfully Anton and his group had
already worked with this Observatory on
previous experiments and we were able to
somehow convince the director to give us
discretionary time to do this crazy
thing
so here are some pretty amazing
panoramas of the experimental sites in
La Palma taken by by Jason
and
there's a bird's eye view from Google
Earth showing the 4.2 meter William
herzl telescope and 3.6 meter telescope
National Galileo the entangled particle
Source was sitting on a landing pad in
front of the Nordic optical telescope in
a little container which I'll talk more
about but you can see that it's right in
the middle because we needed line of
sight
between all three sites
and we really needed such big telescopes
to get enough light from the these
really really faint distant quasars in
the limited time we had on the
telescopes
so since since I was working on the
design Theory software and data analysis
for the experiment my role in The
Experiment was remote so sadly I didn't
actually get to go to the Canary Islands
so this is why in the documentary my
name gets mentioned very very briefly
and I think if you look really closely
you'll see about a quarter of my head on
Jason's laptop on a video chat
and we so we nominally had three nights
on on the telescopes two hour blocks in
January of 2018 and I was in charge
along with Jason of selecting which
pairs of quasars we'd actually observed
so
since everyone was relying on us we
didn't want one of our laptops crashing
to me in the end of the experiment so we
hedged our Bets with Jason going to La
Palma and me staying in San Diego where
I had access to other computational
resources and several backup computers
and you know over several years we'd
each written parallel versions of
software which would select the optimal
pairs of quasars to observe with these
two telescopes at any given time from a
huge database which started out at about
a 1.5 million objects but we eventually
cut that down about 60 000 of the best
candidates
But ultimately due to weather and other
challenges it was impossible to know
exactly when the experiment would start
so of course we ran many scenarios in
advance but when Bush came to shove our
software had to be able to tell us in
real time the most distant pairs of
quasars we could actually observe at the
same time with these telescopes and this
is a weird thing and we had to write our
own software because nobody in astronomy
wants to to do the kind of thing that we
did for for any sane reasons other than
what we did
so the brighter the quasars were the
faster we would get our experimental
data but since the quasars themselves
vary in brightness and we didn't really
know in advance if we did 10 minutes or
several hours of data and you know it
would be cutting it really really close
if it went beyond our allotted time the
best we could do was was build in to our
software our best estimates for how long
it would take to get the idea we needed
and I'll leave the story of what
actually happened to the documentary but
keep in mind that while we're doing this
high-stakes science there's this
documentary film crew with boom mics and
and cameras hovering over everyone in
the Canary Islands and you know it was
we're all extremely honored to have the
the Nova crew there to tell the story of
our experiment but it really does add to
the pressure when you know things are
going wrong and you're trying to like
solve problems on the Fly and then you
know there there are camera Crews
looking over your shoulder so it's it's
a definitely an interesting experience
to be part of so
speaking of things going wrong I'm going
to tell a story that didn't quite make
it into the documentary but but looking
back there was a near disaster that
almost destroyed our experiment and it
could have been even worse so keep in
mind it's a huge logistical challenge to
get the the experimental Hardware that
was built in Vienna to the Canary
Islands so for example here's a shipping
container that actually served as an
office it's got an air conditioner and
windows and this is where the entangled
particle Source lived it's sitting on
the landing pad in front of the Nordic
optical telescope and there's a couple
of Windows the entangled particles are
generated and they're sent through the
open air out through these windows to
the two other experimental sites but
keep in mind that this Observatory is
2300 meters plus above sea level
and unfortunately a couple of weeks
before we had time on the telescopes
there was a huge storm and the winds got
up to 70 to 80 miles per hour so keep in
mind that this is where the container is
supposed to be
this is where it ended up
so
it literally went end over end
and two hours before this a couple of
people were working inside of it they
they could have been killed thankfully
no one was hurt and and thankfully in
addition to that if it had been a couple
meters to the left it could have gone
over the railing gone over the mountain
and landed in the ocean and and you know
I I If that had happened I would have
thought maybe the universe doesn't want
us to do this experiment
so
you know the window so the office didn't
didn't fare too well and even worse the
most sensitive part of the experiment
the entangled particle source which is a
special Crystal you shine a laser into
it and it shoots out two entangled
photons that was just destroyed in this
accident so our collaborators in Vienna
were heroic in their efforts to Cobble
together a replacement in less than a
couple of weeks from what they could get
a hold of and you know this this type of
equipment is not something you can just
go pick up at Walmart so they really had
to they really had to make it make it
work
and ultimately heavy equipment had to be
brought in to to write the container it
had to be uh weighed down with these
cinder blocks to make sure that the
disaster didn't happen again
and you know here I I really want to
single out uh Dominic rocks a PhD
student and in the xylem's group in
Vienna he's the lead author of our paper
and the key star of the documentary and
he should get an amazing amount of
credit for leading the experimentalists
on the ground in La Palma in both you
know coordinating our response to this
disaster and really making sure that the
experiment actually worked when we had
time on the telescopes and ultimately we
couldn't have done this at all without
the support of folks like Chris Ben at
the observatory and of course Anton and
his entire group from Vienna along with
all the other undergrads grad students
post-docs and researchers in the entire
collaboration science today is really
really a huge huge team effort so though
although Jason and I came up with this
idea there's no way that could it could
have happened without a huge amount of
help with support from people like like
Brian and people like David Leon and
people
too many to mention
um and ultimately uh were just amazing
that uh that they made a documentary
about it so now I'd like to invite you
to enjoy the story of Einstein's Quantum
riddle it's just under an hour and after
that our panel including myself and
Jason David Brin and Brian uh we'll be
happy to take questions from the
audience so thank you so much
hello yeah so any questions no I'm just
kidding that was phenomenal of course
um I'm gonna ask some numbers under your
seat you will find the first page of
your exam wow that's right
so that was really delightful I am going
to ask for audience questions in a few
minutes I'm going to kick off with a
couple questions of my own and
discussion amongst the panelists and
stars I think several stars were born
tonight these two gentlemen to my
immediate left uh we uh we have to leave
this Auditorium or we will all be
collapsed in about 20 minutes so we will
do some uh make a strong effort to
remain on time so first of all that was
an awesome uh documentary they do such
phenomenal work with Nova and um it's
really a testament to the work that you
guys put in for the better part of a
decade
so thank you for that what I want to
start off with first is um is really
kind of the grand Arc of the story as a
personal story as a human story we get
so caught up with all the mesmerizing
science that scientists especially what
is it like to actually participate in
these kinds of discoveries what does it
feel like to understand something it's
one thing to understand something and it
feels so good when you actually do
understand something I've had that
experience once or twice in my life but
to understand something for the first
time in human history that's a
phenomenal accomplishment what does that
feel like for the two of you guys I I
think it's it's really hard to to put in
perspective just
how how amazing it is to you know to
think back to you know thinking about
this idea basically like drawing it on a
napkin
you know a thought experiment
and
uh you know to to actually see it come
to fruition and to actually see uh the
experiment uh successfully produce
results in a way that we could interpret
um it's it's it's sort of a
Indescribable how how awesome it is to
to know that you know you're you're part
of the the scientific story that
stretched back you know many many
generations and you know and that like
um I I can't speak for Jason but but I'm
not Einstein but it's just it's just
amazing to to be following in footsteps
of people like that it's too bad for him
to be wrong again after the the
cosmological constant which he called
his greatest blunder and now this the
guy could have had a good career
Jason what was it like for you
it was great so we discussed this we
wrote a paper and it sort of we're going
around giving talks and people like oh
that's kind of cute that's kind of cute
and I was a little bit worried that this
wasn't going to go anywhere and I I went
to Vienna for a it was a 50th
anniversary of Bell's inequality Belgian
equalizer conference and um I I was sort
of too late to really participate in the
actual conference part but Anton
seilinger the the guy from Vienna
invited me to give a talk to his group
after
and normally you give a seminar and
everyone sort of nods along and there's
one or two questions at the end and and
this time I could tell there were
questions the whole time and afterwards
people were just pounding me with
questions for two hours and everyone was
super excited about this and I finally
felt ah I think this might actually
happen that was that was just a great
feeling that day
and uh from my perspective you know I
was mentioning before the the um before
we met earlier today you know speaking
in conversation uh I was I was watching
a movie a very technical documentary
called Ant-Man and the WASP on an
international flight recently and you
know at a certain point early in the
movie they go we have to go into the
quantum world the realm of the quantum
with entangle and they really kind of
throw all these buzzwords together and
uh and it's clear to me that they
understand that you know at least as
poorly as many physicists do but uh I
want to ask David something what is it
about the quantum world the quantum
realm that so fascinates you and those
of you refined ilk the science fiction
Community why is it so fascinating to
non-specialists very Arcane branch of
mathematical physics after all well I I
do have to emphasize that even though I
got my doctorate about
um 200 meters from here and I am a
member of the priesthood I have my union
card as a as a as a a physicist I'm more
of a Franciscan these are the these are
the Jesuits here working in the Airy
fairy
realm Beyond is that Freeman anime yes
we have
um one of the greats out there uh
Freeman Dyson who's
um uh migrating gradually in a Quantum
set sense with his wife
to a better climate here
from The Institute for advanced study
which is featured in in this show
and he was on this stage here just a few
weeks ago
um so speaking as a Barefoot Franciscan
um I have to tell you that uh um
the the the the the the
Notions of
what the world
um Can can look like
from the point of view of communicating
to you know this wonderful civilization
is the thing that strikes me is shows
like Nova
no priesthood in the past that
interpreted
um
what the world
was about and what God's words were if
you believe
was no priesthood was ever so eager to
share
so eager that whatever degree
that the phys the scientists plus good
storytellers
could possibly
um achieve to communicate what your tax
dollars paid for
um you are you are uh you are part of
this adventure you aren't kept outside
uh you're welcome to come in and and I I
invite all of you to find out when the
seminars are held here on campus
you can come and eat your lunch in the
back of the room
they won't like it if you sit in front
with the Nobel Prize winners till the
third or fourth time
but other than that come and eat your
lunch
so along with the concept of the you
know microscopic universe that's
explored here you guys also played out a
role on the grandest cosmic stage itself
which is the vast bulk of the cosmos and
and to think about connecting the
smallest Quantum objects with the entire
Cosmos is really a phenomenal result and
a lot of times these two things emerge
and are synchronized again in Concepts
from science fiction things like
wormholes and extra dimensions and even
the Multiverse I know you guys have
thought about this so what are some of
your thoughts about this and why it
resonates so deeply uh with with our
curiosity
so when you're thinking about
entanglement and you're thinking about
something that seems like it's very far
away somehow affecting something
you know even farther away
one of the things that people have
speculated about in science fiction
which is now a kind of actually become a
reputable subject in physics is the idea
that uh perhaps the idea of wormholes
which comes up in Einstein's theory of
general relativity the idea that there's
shortcuts between different places in
space and time
it some people are taking seriously the
idea that entangled particles might
actually be described by a sort of
quantum scale Wormhole and you know
toward the end of the Nova episode
um people were talking about speculative
ideas where you can actually think about
entanglement itself as being sort of the
fundamental ingredient of nature in a
new Theory of physics there's a certain
sense in which entanglement is more
fundamental than quantum mechanics it's
really just this question of if you have
two places in space and time two
particles are they independent of each
other or not and In classical physics
it's possible for those things to be
independent of each other but in in
quantum physics and perhaps in a new
physical Theory which combines quantum
theory and Einstein's theory of gravity
maybe it's just not possible for two
places to really be independent of one
another and maybe
there is a picture in which space and
time are emergent Concepts and you could
actually Envision a network of quantum
wormholes between all these entangled
particles
you know if you were able to like go
down into the level of where Ant-Man was
and I've been there and it looked
exactly like that
um
then then you know maybe you know you
you
would see these connections between
things that naively look like they're
really really far away from each other
but maybe in this new physical theory if
they're connected in this way they're
actually really really close together
I just want to point out thinking about
this and thinking back to when I met
Andy's uh I met Andy actually through
the origin of this the origin story
itself actually relies on a series of
networked and interconnected and
correlated events but it all began with
your mother who's in the front row who I
met about seven years ago and I think
it's interesting to think about these
origin stories and if one thing had
changed a slight difference you know
maybe you wouldn't be here tonight maybe
we would but but I think it's important
to acknowledge how these things come
together in most magical ways yeah and
interestingly speaking of entanglement
my parents at one point met David Brynn
randomly on an airplane
and and you know they they you know my
dad had read his books and so it uh it
it is pretty amazing you know and that
you know when you come to think of it
when you meet anybody in life you know
Jason and I met in graduate school think
about all the things that had had to
happen for for that to be possible yeah
it's just it's pretty mind-blowing oh
and in the uh Clark Center archives
there may be you might find two did we
do two together or three we did three
different the three physicists and
nobody asked us to which one was the
tenor or to sing but uh oh my God we did
well one on Multiverse uh and what were
the other two uh we talked about the the
physics of free will yeah and then uh
you know the the mind of God oh yes you
know a very very simple subject
yes which brings me to my next and maybe
final question depending on how many
questions you all have out there uh so
at the end Anton's eilinger uh the one
of the the leaders of this branch of
research he starts talking about what
Einstein thought about you know the one
question that Einstein wanted to
understand was what was going on in the
mind of God and I wonder you know I
don't know your particular views on that
particular subject but but if you could
ask Einstein or tell Einstein something
after all your peripatetic wanderings
and space-time what would it be what
would you most want to tell the great
Maestro physics Albert Einstein Jason
start with you no I I think I would have
liked to explain Bell's inequalities and
ask you know just have it start a
discussion about
you know when when he was thinking about
all these things uh it was mostly a
philosophical matter of of whether there
was some underlying reality or or
whether the bore Schrodinger description
was right
and uh it wasn't until after he had died
that people realized that this this is
not just a philosophical issue but
something that was experimentally
testable and the experiments came out in
a certain way so you know I would sort
of like to present him with theoretical
and experimental evidence and say
you know all right now what
David yeah I'm I was told by my father
and I never really confirmed it but I
was told by my father that I saw
Einstein play the violin when I was
three
um and the stories must have been
traumatic because actually it's a weird
thing and I've never told anybody about
myself and that is that I couldn't look
at a picture of Albert Einstein until I
was 12.
it creeped me out
that's spooky it was spooky it was it
was spooky but um other than that I
would say the you know I'm not going to
waste any time pitying Albert Einstein
uh for you know getting a couple of
things wrong
um it it uh
the theological issues are another
matter
um and it it's it's very clear that we
can
uh chase down God whether he's there or
not one of the things that zelinker was
talking about was carving no no it was
Kaiser carving away
what's left
and I dispute with a lot of my
um uh atheist friends I say no no no no
you have all you've done is chased him
out of 99 of the possible
uh he's still giggling the god of the
gaps
whether he's there or not you know he he
you can still hear the giggle no
famously he said God does not play dice
with the universe and and he used to
speak quite reverently about it and yet
we have great evidence that he was
probably an atheist in some ways uh Andy
what would you most want to tell
Einstein and if you could somehow
communicate maybe you can be on the
beyond the realm of the the current
well it's interesting because you know
because he's he's so mythologized in our
culture uh whenever the idea of Einstein
being wrong comes up people you know get
really excited and interested and that I
would say that that uh
Einstein to the extent that he was wrong
was wrong in some of the most
interesting ways yes in the history of
physics
um and and you know although the
documentary
um kind of you know tied it up in a nice
little bow I would say that uh the the
questions that Einstein raised
um that that lead to the idea that there
are possible loopholes in these
experiments they have not in my opinion
all been definitively addressed and that
that's why we need to do experiments
like the one we did and there there need
to be future experiments to keep pushing
things further and further absolutely
and and so you know I I would want to
talk to him about just as Jason would I
would like to see his reaction to the
state of the art of knowledge today and
and then also you know I would love to
ask him okay what do you think we should
do next
well he also famously said imagination
is more important than knowledge and
we're here in the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination so I want to take
questions from the audience uh and we
have some microphones I believe
somewhere where there's one over here
and there's one probably over there
symmetry holds so make your way to the
microphone so you can be recorded and
publicized and encrypted by those
Chinese scientists that we saw and I
will start we have a good turnout good
um so I'll I'll begin over here and then
we'll just alternate for the remaining
15 minutes or so yes please hey
gentlemen two quick questions one is has
anyone
um done York been able to repeat your
experiments and get the same results and
two are there any Nobel implications for
this particular work in physics it no I
I I would say that we're not going to
win a Nobel Prize for this because
um most of the people in the physics
Community probably expected us to find
results that are consistent with quantum
mechanics and we certainly did too a
Nobel Prize would have only been a
result if we found something that was
completely unexpected That Was Then
confirmed by others and as far as
whether or not our current results uh
have been confirmed by others so far
we're the only group to do an experiment
with quasars but um our our competitors
and and slash collaborators including
John Wayne Pan's grouping China they've
also done another Cosmic battle test
where they used stars in their own
Galaxy similar to what we did in our
first Cosmic Bill test and and all those
results are consistent with quantum
mechanics being correct but but so far
no one else has done a a cosmic Bell
test with quasars but we hope somebody
does a quick question for you two guys
now those two
um uh quasars the oldest one is eight
billion years old is that the oldest one
was a a shade over 12 billion years 12
billion years okay so they were chosen
in opposite directions
so
at what point after the big bang were
they causally in reach of each other was
it was it before or after the 380 000
years so
um the about the universe is about 13.8
billion years old and they've all
watched big big Banks Theory and they
can sing the song fair enough and and uh
the if you look at the the furthest
place in in time where something could
have jointly influenced both of the
quasars that was a shade over 13 billion
yours so so it wasn't all the way back
it wasn't all the way back it wasn't all
the way back and and uh we would love to
do a future experiment where we use even
more distant fainter quasars but we
would have needed bigger telescopes and
more time in order to make that happen
yes and another camera crew to get Andy
on film more often yes sir this is the
second time that I've seen this I saw it
on TV when it came out and I was
interested in seeing it again
um the thing that I sort of came away
with was if you influence one entangled
particle instantaneously you influence
the other which immediately brought to
mind that that was instantaneous like
faster than the speed of light which Dr
Freeman said twice during his
introduction you can't transmit
information faster than the speed of
light this seems to like contradict that
the only unless those two particles are
actually exist at the same place in the
same time and you're you're influencing
the same particle so it's it's a little
subtle you
something seems to be happening faster
than the speed of light but it's it's
really the establishment of these
correlations that's happening uh you
can't use this to communicate because
any one person
sees a completely random result no
matter what the other person does to the
other particle
so in order to tell that the
correlations between them were
established in this interesting way
after they do their measurements they
then just have to communicate normally
and compare results and that always has
to happen at or below the speed of light
so there's there's nothing that somebody
on one side can do to their particle to
influence
what's going to happen to the other part
I was always going to look random to
both people so it's sort of it's a weird
in-between land between
uh you know what exactly is happening
faster than light is is a little bit
subtle Einstein is still Reigns Supreme
when it comes to actually telling
somebody at a distance something that
they would like to information they'd
like to have
um so if you if you do this experiment
uh and and you have have it be a light
year apart
the correlation is going to be
instantaneous if action at a distance
works
neither person is going to know this
until light has transmitted information
for a year
yeah it seems to violate the uh
the the spirit of Einstein's theory of
relativity but it doesn't actually
violate the letter of Relativity and the
the thing that we can say for sure is
that uh you know if Brian measures one
half of the entangled particle pair then
he instantly knows something about what
Jason would measure in the future
um and so
um we now don't think that anything
Brian does to make the measurement
instantaneously
changes the state of Jason's particle in
a way that you know is instantaneous you
could you have to do the the checking
later and that that happens at slower
than the speed of light the one the one
possible use is that some kind of
military or commercial decision
um if you make it here
you are associate one light year away
may may know something about what you
decided
but that's again that's kind of iffy
okay we only have five minutes left so I
want to go back over here is there a
question yes young man
um so in terms of of you talked about
earlier about wormholes and the
implications that it could have but do
you think that your results could
provide evidence for something like
string theory which has compactified
Dimensions so you could potentially see
results that look like entanglement but
are actually not traveling faster than
the speed of light
I I think that uh our our experiment
um unfortunately is not powerful enough
to
um test something like string theory
which is a candidate for a possible way
of taking quantum mechanics and general
relativity together and merging them
into you know a uh
a coherent whole that that agrees with
each other uh but but I I do think that
future experiments that involve
cosmology that involve using the
universe as a laboratory are probably
our best bet for gaining experimental
evidence for these new theories it's
becoming harder and harder to build
particle accelerators that reach the the
energy scales that are necessary so I
would say that our experiment is
definitely in the spirit of trying to
learn about these new physical theories
um you know eventually we want to
find a new physical theory that makes uh
predictions that are slightly different
than quantum mechanics where we can
understand what the new physics has to
be in order to explain that
okay now we come to the lightning round
uh because we only have a few minutes
left before we engage in our black hole
brownies and Quantum cookies so we'll go
over there sure thing quickly please so
uh I also am absolutely fascinated by
Quantum phenomena one phenomenon I find
really interesting is something that the
pearlab at Princeton has looked into in
the past which regards
um the human our ability to influence
random number generators and I was
wondering if you guys happen to have any
uh you know input on that regarding you
know what maybe something you've heard
about in this working in this field or
not
well an interesting question is well how
how good are humans at producing random
numbers for for example
um
pretty bad pretty bad is the answer yes
yes I I I absolutely agree
um and the uh it's certainly uh an
interesting idea to uh instead of
letting quasars make the experimental
choices uh we could let humans make the
choices but in order to make sure that
no uh influences at the speed of light
are slower could affect the results
human reaction time is slow and so you'd
probably need to have one person on the
earth and one person on the moon in
order to make sure that that no hidden
influences could affect things uh it's
it's a separate question which I think
is what you're asking about about
whether or not the human mind could
influence a random number generator
that's external to to a human and I I
would say that that if if that happened
my mind would be blown and and uh you
know I
um I I I'm skeptical that that's
possible I I think uh I it's certainly
worth testing the limits of the human
mind scientifically and in whatever ways
are possible
um but uh
I I would be extremely surprised if if I
could
reliably change the outcome of a Quantum
process that's far away from me so I'll
take one more question then we'll
adjourn for Refreshments outside where
you can engage with the scientists and
the panelists as well yes sir assuming
the Big Bang why isn't everything
already correlated and entangled ah so
that's that's a very good question and
it depends on which which model of the
big bang you you look at
so this the sort of
Maybe original model where you just
Trace back the expansion of the universe
that we see today you just trace it back
trace it back trace it back and you ask
at any point
um what
so say say the light was emitted from
this quasar
approximately a billion years after the
universe was created and you ask what
could have influenced that
uh if you really Trace back
all of the matter in our universe that
matter and light in our universe
it turns out that
a quasar on one side of the sky could
not have influenced a quasar on the
other side of the sky even though
everything in the Big Bang was an
incredibly small space it expanded so
fast
that light that left in this direction
couldn't catch up to something in this
direction
because they're expanding away too fast
so it's it's subtle because you think
that in the Big Bang yeah everything was
all on top of each other certainly
everything had a lot of time to mix
but the expansion in the beginning was
was too fast for for that to really work
out now there are
problems with this and and people have
proposed extensions and one of the
extensions is the theory of cosmic
inflation
and that is specifically designed to
allow
pasts of these things to to interact so
that everything could could mix
thermalization smoothing out one way of
doing it yeah and so uh there's
reasons to believe that that that did
happen
and and then again it it could it could
be that something way back in that
period of cosmic inflation affected all
the things that we see
um
but yeah that's sort of a
yeah I would say that if if inflation
happened uh then the best we can do is
to progressively use more and more
distant astronomical sources and push
this loophole back further and further
into the inflationary Epoch but uh this
loophole uh that's the best we could
ever do if inflation happened and your
question is a valid one and it would
still leave open the possibility that
everything was was predetermined at the
origin of the of the Epic of inflation
would put the bang into the Big Bang so
that that's a possibility that can't be
ruled out with the kinds of experiments
that we're thinking about
okay well I do want to thank everybody
for coming out on a Monday evening in
San Diego and invite you to entangle and
mix and mingle with the panelists
outside thank you all